well forgive me for asking this question
but how often did the two of you take a
case that's maybe a little bit too dare
I say intimidating or maybe too
controversial you're asking the wrong
folks because it those are like oh great
what an example two years ago the talk
of Sundance was a film little black and
white film horror film that was shot
surreptitiously at Disney World
it was a talk of talk of Sundance every
publication that said anything about the
film said isn't it too bad it won't be
released oh it can't be released there
are hundreds of people in the background
copyright material trademarks logos
they'll never get it released so where
did the film land up in our office we
worked with the filmmaker
a couple little tweaks and it got
released got insured that's what we love
to do yeah yeah we kind of I think we're
going to thrive off of those
controversial not necessarily
controversial but I think it's more
where people have a preconceived idea of
what the law is and so much of that is
based on policy created by Studios that
doesn't necessarily apply to independent
filmmakers and so a lot of a lot of
issues that snow makers think are really
difficult I mean a very tangible example
is people wearing t-shirts with the logo
on it or a hat how many times where I
get the question of can we use that or I
have to blur this logo out absolutely
not you don't have to blur that logo out
you know you may want to because maybe
you want that brand to give you money
for product placement but legally you
have every right to use that trademark
in the manner in which it's intended and
you're even looking at me like really so
there's so many issues like that so I
don't want controversial I don't think
is the right word but it's more just
taking these principles that people
believe are true and dispelling them of
that yeah we often talk about the worst
sensor in the world
which are the scissors in your mind okay
thinking some have these ideas that they
can't they shouldn't don't get in
trouble if they do and we work with them
so that they can be insured which covers
the issue of what happens if somebody
comes after us and and film after film
after film that are really difficult I
don't know if your camera is picking it
up but right behind us as a poster for
room 237 a third of that film was
comprised of clips from The Shining in a
film that the Kubrick estate would hate
and they did and they call and we deal
with them but did we have insurance in
place and all we ever did was organize a
nice disclaimer at the front which was
perfectly satisfactory to the filmmaker
in fact worked in the filmmakers favor
actually there was on the screen for a
long time and made the audience laugh
and and also set up the fact that you
know this this is how these professors
deconstruct the shining not the way the
Kubrick's deconstruct the shiny gosh we
have so many examples yeah there's a lot
like that and they are they're exciting
for us because we feel we opened the
door to filmmakers that they didn't know
could it be opened at all you know and
when we get that satisfaction from a
client it's so satisfying satisfying for
us you know to get that and to for a
client to go wow thank you I could have
never made this movie without you and I
don't think a lot of lawyers get that
yeah it's very blessed request the first
line on our website is helping artists
tell their story the their way and
that's what we're all about so when
somebody comes in as you say with us
scare but it's scary to maybe other
lawyers maybe scary to them we just
wring our hands and say oh let us jump
into this
well we had a we had a great one last
can the talk of the of the festival was
a film called welcome to New York it was
a biopic about Dominique strauss-kahn
and his predilection for New York hotel
maid's told from the hotel maid's point
of view we couldn't talk to her because
she'd signed a confidentiality agreement
certainly Dominique strauss-kahn wasn't
going to talk to us and his wife
depicted by Jacqueline Bisset Dominique
strauss-kahn was played by Gerard yeah
yeah what you know it people thought
this had never get released that not
only got released it was shown at the
Cannes Film Festival everybody was
talking about it and we actually in that
case did not get any phone calls in
spite of scenes that were made up
between mr. and mrs. Khan we worked with
the filmmaker on how to do that so that
it was being sharable that's always the
key for us can we get the me you know
insurance is that where this safe harbor
clause or I maybe I'm you know
distorting the meaning of it but is that
where this all comes into play what
comes into play on copyright
infringement questions ok with the
Dominique strauss-kahn example those are
personal rights a very different area of
the law and in escape from tomorrow the
black and white horror film shot
surreptitiously at Disney World
you had personal rights of all the
people in the background you had a lot
of various fair use issues with
trademark and copyrights that were
present in the film so yeah at all that
one had everything right it was the full
basket
you